in the video on the molecular structure
of DNA we saw that DNA was made up is
made up typically made up of two strands
where the the backbone of each of the
strands is made up of phosphate
alternating between a noose and
different colors a phosphate group and
then you have a sugar you have a you
have a phosphate group and then you have
a sugar and then you have a sugar and
then you have a phosphate group and then
you have a sugar and so I could draw the
strand something like this so phosphate
and then we have a sugar clip so let me
so let me just draw all the phosphates
ahead of time so you have the phosphates
on that end and then you have the sugars
and you see the same thing on the on the
other strand as well where we have
phosphate phosphate with the sugar then
another phosphate then a sugar then
another phosphate let me circle the
sugars as well so you have a sugar there
and then you have the sugar there as
well so on the other strand it's also
going to look like this so let me draw
the phosphates
I'm just abstracting them now so the
phosphate and then you have the sugars
in between the phosphates and what links
them you can think of them as the rungs
on the ladder these are the
complementary nitrogenous bases and the
reason why we call them nitrogenous
bases I actually forgot to talk about in
the last videos is that these nitrogen's
are really electronegative and they can
take up more hydrogen protons they have
they have an extra lone pair the
nitrogen's have an extra lone pair that
can be used up under the right
conditions to potentially stop up more
hydrogen protons now a lot of people ask
well if you have these nitrogenous bases
here why is DNA called an acid why is it
called an acid well the first thing is
that the the basic properties of the
nitrogenous base are offset to to a good
degree based on the fact that they're
able to hydrogen bond with each other
and that's actually Able's that's what
actually forms these these rungs the the
rungs of the ladder when these
complementary nitrogenous bases form
these hydrogen bonds with each other but
even more the reason why we call it an
acid is the phosphate
groups when they're protonated are acids
now the reason why we tend to draw them
deprotonated is what they're so acidic
that if you put them in a in a in a
neutral solution they're going to be
deprotonated so this would this is the
form that you're more likely to find it
in the nucleus of an actual cell once
it's actually already be deep once it's
already deprotonated but in general
phosphate groups are considered acidic
and if I were to draw a kind of a more
pure phosphate group and I talked about
this already in the last video I would
have I would have it protonated and so I
wouldn't draw that negative charge like
that so that's just a review of view of
last time but let's actually actually
just let me just I already started
abstracting it let's abstract it further
so let's let's draw the nitrogenous
bases a little bit so I have I have
thymine here and I will do thymine in
this green color so this right over
there is thymine so this is attached to
the mean and the complementary the
complimentary nitrogenous base to
thymine is adenine is adenine which I
will do let's see I'm running out of
colors here let's see adenine I'll do
this in an orange color it's got so many
nitrogen's on it so actually so let me
so it actually should include that
hydrogen right over there so this right
over here is adenine adenine and they
form that you have these hydrogen bonds
between them right over here because if
partially negative and positive charges
on either end that are attracted to each
other and then we go to this rung one
rung below it and what is going on well
let's see we have I really am running
out of colors here we have this this
nitrogenous base is cytosine this
nitrogenous base right over here is
cytosine this nitrogenous base here is
cytosine and it is paired up with
guanine it is paired up with guanine the
guanine in this color so it is it is
paired up with guanine right over there
and we even saw this in the in the
introductory video to DNA now you might
say oh look these two strands see
parallel to each other and in some ways
that is that is true but there might be
something other than another interesting
thing that you might have noticed is the
direction in which they they are
oriented I guess it's the best way to
phrase it if we edit and you especially
see that when you focus in on the sugars
notice the the sugar is over here the
deoxyribose this is or the things that
are the parts of the nucleotide that
come from deoxy ribose you see the
oxygens on the top of the ribose on the
top of these five-member rings the
oxygen is on top well on this side the
oxygen is on the bottom and so they are
actually in different orientations here
the oxygens pointing up here the oxygen
is pointing down and to get a little bit
more concrete about that we can number
the carbons on the ribose to think about
the directions and use those numbers of
the carbons to to describe the different
directions so let's number our carbons
so when ribose so this is rye but these
are both ribose we saw that in the
molecular structure of DNA videos when
we're talking about DNA we're talking
with deoxyribose so it does not have it
does not have a it does not instead of
having a hydroxyl group on the number
two carbon it just has a it just has a
hydrogen so instead of having a hydroxyl
group on the number two carbon it just
has a hydrogen but let's actually number
them so this is the 1 prime carbon
starting at the carbonyl group let me do
that in a different color so this is the
1 prime carbon and I'm just numbering
them starting at the carbonyl group 1
prime 2 prime three prime 4 prime 5
prime and then when you look at it as a
ring this was the 1 prime this is the 2
prime this is the 3 prime this is the 4
prime this is the 5 prime or if you were
to number them on this diagram right
over here actually in the DNA molecule
this is the 1 prime this is the 2 prime
carbon
this is the 3 prime carbon this is the 4
prime carbon and this is the 5 prime
carbon and so one way to think about it
is we go fasta fête group and it's
connected it's connected with what we
call
phosphodiester linkages phosphodiester
linkage is that that's what's less
essentially allowing these backbones to
link up but we're going from phosphate
to five prime carbon to and then through
the sugar we go from to the three prime
carbon then we go to another phosphate
then we go to the five pi prime carbon
let me label that this is the five prime
carbon then we go to the three prime
carbon and that just comes straight out
of just numbering these starting with
the carbon that was the number one
carbon foot when in a straight chain
form it's at the carbonyl it for it's
part of the carbonyl group but you see
we're going from five we go phosphate
five prime three prime phosphate five
prime three prime phosphate so one way
to describe the orientation is saying
hey we're going in the direction from
five prime to three prime so we could
say we could say that we're going from
five prime we're going from five prime
to three prime that way on the left-hand
chain and what are we doing on the
right-hand chain
well let's number them again so this is
the 1 prime carbon now this thing
relative to this is upside-down it's
inverted so one prime two prime three
prime four prime five prime I can do it
up here one prime carbon two prime
carbon three carbon four prime carbon
five prime carbon here you're going from
phosphate three prime five prime
phosphate three prime five prime
phosphate so the way that the sugars are
oriented if you're going from top to
bottom the way we're looking here you're
going from three prime to five prime so
on the right hand side you are it's
three prime five prime and so if you
want to draw an arrow from five prime to
three prime you could you could look at
it like that and so you could say these
are parallel but since they are
essentially oriented in they're pointing
in different directions even though
they're actually parallel we would call
the structure of DNA and tie parallel so
this would be an anti anti anti parallel
structure of DNA so these two strands
they're complementary they're defined by
each other the thymine bonds with the
adenine the cytosine bonds with the
guanine or they they they they're they
are tracted to each other through these
hydrogen bonds but the two backbones
they're pointed in different directions
and another interesting thing to think
about since we're talking about the
molecular structure of DNA is how do
these things form how do these things
know to orient the in this way and part
of what plays part of that role is the
fact that these phosphate groups are
negative so you think these things that
have outright negative charge they're
going to try to get as far away from
each other as possible and then when
they you know they just keep kind of
orienting getting far away from each
other and these are long these are very
very very very long molecules in the
introductory video to DNA we talked
about how long these these chromosomes
are how many base pairs we actually have
in these are long molecules so all of
these phosphate groups on either strand
they want to get away from each other
and then these things want to these
things want to get close to each other
because of the hydrogen bonds and so
that's what helps form this actual
ladder structure so DNA fascinating
molecule we could speak for days about
it it's actually mind-blowing when you
think about its implications for for who
we are but hopefully this gives you a
better sense of what it is molecular
Lily molecular lis I cannot say it
molecular Li